es el tercer lugar más sagrado para
musulmanes quienes lo conocen como El
noble santuario y el más sagrado para
los judíos quienes lo llaman el monte
del templo este sitio ha estado siempre
en el centro de las disputas entre
israelíes y palestinos y ahora un nuevo
motivo amenaza con avivar las tensiones
la visita del ministro de seguridad
Nacional de Israel el ultraderechista y
tamamar vengavir y que autoridades
palestinas califican como una
provocación
es un desafío para los sentimientos del
pueblo palestino y hacemos un llamado a
todo nuestro pueblo que frustró el
complot que tiene como objetivo
convertir el santuario en un templo
judío y esto es una violación a todas
las normas valores acuerdos leyes
internacionales y compromisos de Israel
se paseó brevemente por la periferia del
complejo por primera vez desde que
asumió el cargo En el gabinete de
ultraderecha y según un funcionario
israelí el ministro no incumplió el
acuerdo de estatus quo heredado del
conflicto de 1967 que permite a los no
musulmanes visitar el lugar con la
condición de
desde hace tiempo bengaví reclama un
mayor acceso para los judíos el monte
del templo está abierto para todos Sí
también para judíos en el gobierno del
que soy miembro no habrá discriminación
racista y los judíos visitarán el monte
del templo en los últimos años se ha
visto un creciente número de
nacionalistas que suben a este lugar a
rezar de manera oculta en el año 2000 la
visita a la Explanada del entonces líder
israelí de la oposición el derechista
Ariel Sharon fue recibida como una
provocación y al día siguiente se
produjeron sangrientos enfrentamientos
que marcaron el inicio de la segunda
intifada